oh so you want to catch them all here's
a quick overview of Pokemon go with the
biggest tips and tricks so you can get
to the top of that gym first up where to
find Pokemon if you live in a city
you're gonna be chock-full of pocus tops
and Pokemon but if you don't travel to
locations where there are community
parks art or buildings places of
interest poke a stops refresh every 5
minutes you can visit them an unlimited
amount of time check back often and get
eggs and incense and more also if your
bag is full keep going your character is
getting XP onto the map if you see grass
shaking a Pokemon may or may not reside
there but you get a higher chance of
encountering a wild Pokemon if you see a
bunch of hearts on any pokey stop that
means there's a lure there and there's a
lot more Pokemon to follow stand in the
lure and just hang out they'll come to
you the footprint next to the Pokemon
tab lets you know the proximity of the
wild Pokemon the closer you are the less
footprints there will be selecting a
Pokemon and the tracker will give you a
pulse when you're getting close 3
footsteps means it's about three rings
away two footsteps means two rings and
so on no rings means you're there click
on that Pokemon and it will appear in
ten seconds once you're in the zone of
trying to catch the Pokemon the color of
the ring when catching the Pokemon
refers to the difficulty Green is easy
yellow is moderate and red is difficult
try and hit him on the head if you're
having trouble change out of
augmented-reality mode you'll see that
option in the upper right you'll have
less depth of field and an easier time
hitting your target if he does get away
you should be able to see him on the map
and click and try again but what happens
if you've already caught 10 zubats catch
them again catch duplicates catching
them can give you polka candy which you
need to power up and evolve your Pokemon
catch them and return them to Professor
Willow you can click on your Pokemon
stats and then hit transfer but be
careful which ones you transfer check
out their CP or combat power each
individual Pokemon is assigned CP at
capture it indicates how well that
particular Pokemon will perform in
battle as you gain XP and become a
higher level trainer the CP of the
Pokemon you capture will Jenner
be hired so one Zubat might be 10 CP and
another 56 CP keep the higher one
transfer the other don't waste your time
evolving and powering your pokemon right
away you could power up your Charmander
to 100 CP and then find another
Charmander at 150 CP the next day wait
only power up your highest evolved
Pokemon give it some time
here's an overview of your items
pokeballs are your basic tool for
catching Pokemon but great Balls unlock
at level 12 and they're better ultra
balls which unlock at level 20 are even
more useful for high-level Pokemon all
three can be obtained at pokey stops
once you've reached the right level
potions super potion and hyper potions
allow for Pokemon to be healed in
battles revives allows the revival and
the lucky egg this is an item that
doubles the experience you gain the next
half hour after use raspberries can be
used on higher level Pokemon to prevent
them from running away level up your
character quickly and earn badges catch
as many Pokemon as you can to earn
experience points or XP increase your
trainer level each capture Awards XP
based on the kind of Pokemon you caught
even if you've caught it before and you
also get more XP based on the accuracy
of your throw the higher level you are
the more rare Pokemon you'll come across
remember how I told you you got eggs at
pokus tops use an incubator to hatch it
these eggs are stored under your caught
Pokemon screen swipe to the right eggs
can be placed in an incubator by
selecting the one you'd like to hatch
the distance needed to travel to hatch
an egg is under each egg everyone gets
one free incubator that lasts forever
any extras you find or receive from
leveling up only last three hatches then
they break once in an incubator walk
around and it will hatch once you meet
the distance quota candy is also
obtained by hatching eggs yes your app
needs to be open to reach that distance
quota keep your app open so click those
Pokemon and level up leveling up gives
you lures in cents and incubators so you
don't need to buy these if you're
worried about spending money for coins
and get coins by having Pokemon in gyms
this is the defender bonus there's a
shield icon in the shop section that you
can refresh every 21 hours 10 poker
coins and 500 stars
are given per Pokemon a day you can have
up to 10 Pokemon in 10 different gyms
for total of 100 polka coins and 5000
Stardust a day but first you need to get
in that gym once you're level 5 you can
join an alliance if you take on a gym of
your own alliance your Pokemon will
never faint their HP will reduce to 1
and they'll need healing but they won't
faint a gym has a max of 3 Pokemon
trainers or defenders at any time if you
find a gym of your Alliance with only
one or two Pokemon in it you can just
add your Pokemon you don't have to fight
them drop a Pokemon in there and keep
walking free defender bonus but if
there's no spots you're gonna have to
fight a trainer when you're in combat
it's not turn-based its real-time click
once for a basic attack swipe to dodge
hold down a click for a special attack
if you have more CPU consider not
dodging and just click click click click
click you'll probably win after you've
won do not put your best Pokemon in the
gym second or third best is better
you can't recall your Pokemon what sits
in a gym and you'll need it to fight
other gyms once it's beaten though it
will return to you so keep your
favourite with you finally you've
probably noticed that you've lost all
your battery playing this game you're
gonna probably want to buy an external
battery but another option is to use the
battery saver mode which is found in the
settings of your Pokemon Go app once you
click on it the screen dims and only the
Pokemon logo shows it still tracks your
steps need will vibrate when a Pokemon
shows up when you lift your phone to
your face the screen will go back to
normal that's all I have for you right
now but be sure to stay tuned to
games.com for the latest on Pokemon go